au sol 90 visage devant la pyramide de
chaussures symbolise les 90 civils
victimes chaque jour dans le monde de
bombardements le combat initiale de
handicap international contre les mines
antipersonnel s'est élargi à
l'utilisation d'autres armes et d'autres
méthodes de combat en près d'un quart de
siècle des succès tout de même ont été
obtenues on avait gagné un combat
c'était l'interdiction des mines
antipersonnel
donc oui nous en sommes satisfaits et
puis ensuite
par la suite donc là on aimerait bien
que les politiques nous entende
d'où la pétition
suzie tapis pour réunir un million de
signatures pour faire reconnaître le
droit à 2 c
si vit la population tourangelle semble
sensible en tout cas à la cause de
handicap international
dès le début d'après midi une belle
pyramide ont été formés sur le boulevard
heurteloup de nombreuses personnes
venant jeté des chaussures et signer la
pétition
à l'image de ses pensionnaires d'un
établissement pour adultes handicapés de
ballan-miré c'était pour les
sensibiliser à l'handicap qui est
différent de celui qu'ils vivent eux
mêmes quoi ils ont montré qu'ils avaient
une autre sonde handicap dans le monde
que les gens qui sont handicapés de la
naissance en pratique par les bombes
milan des personnels et pour ceux qu'on
donne des chaussures pour donner à des
personnes qu'ils ont besoin en afrique
ou des personnes qui sont pauvres
et des personnes qu'ils ont vraiment
besoin pour s'habiller
on va faire le plaisir pour les autres
et puis pour la joie il n'est pas trop
tard pour contribuer à cette pyramide de
chaussures tourangelle les militantes de
handicap international seront encore
présents demain dans l'après midi à
partir de 14 heures
[Musique]